right let's just get to some of the best
bits in this or the most interesting
bits in this 25-page report here you go
um
successful candidate Mr Richard Sharp
failed to disclose potential perceived
conflicts of interest to the panel that
goes right to the heart of this what did
Richard Sharp tell the panel for the
interview at the BBC board
um Mr shop informed the Prime Minister
he wished to apply for the chair of the
bbbc board that was one of the areas
where he went wrong and secondly Mr
Sharp also informed the former prime
minister he was going to meet with a
cabinet secretary to attempt to
introduce him to a person who might
assist him with his personal finances
this is all about that loan guarantee
that Richard Sharp helped Boris Johnson
with
um by setting him up with a distant
relative these matters gave rise here
you go to a potential conflict of
interest there is a risk of a perception
that Mr Sharp was recommended for
appointment because he assisted the
former prime minister in a private
Financial matter and or that he
influenced the former prime minister to
recommend him by informing him of his
application before he submitted it
um so that there you go a breach of the
governance code you can see there that
is what it comes down to that is what
Richard Shaw mentioned in that interview
this morning
um he does go on to say though in this
report that a breach of the governance
code does not invalidate the appointment
that was saying that Richard Sharp
touched on as well in his interview but
he has still decided to go and I sort of
show you one more bit very quickly if we
have time
um here this is all about
the pressure really that number 10 was
putting on make giving Richard Sharp
that job a BBC chairman of course the
Prime Minister does play a role in that
it was very clear that after speaking to
Boris Johnson after helping him
um with that loan guarantee he was a
preferred candidate number 10 commented
um to the Department of culture media
and Sport thought in November 2020 that
Mr Sharp looked like a strong candidate
goes on to say number 10 support for
Richard Sharp was made known to the
panel he was the only candidate
identified to the panel as having his
candidacy supported by ministers well
there you go after a long wait we have
this 25 five page report making clear
um that Richard Shaw there was a
perceived conflict of interest Richard
Sharp did breach the rules we know now
obviously that he has decided to go